hello we're glad you've joined us for
this webinar clinical uses of mass
spectrometry i am michelle ashton of
laberd's and i'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by laberd's the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration it is
made possible by an open educational
grant from Agilent Agilent has had no
input in the selection of speakers
content or mode of presentation let's
get started you can pose questions to
the speakers during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button to enlarge the slide
window click on the arrows at the top
right hand corner of the presentation
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window will report your
problem by typing it into the ask a
question box I now present today's
speakers Neena Audrey and Phillip
Fatima's
both are from the laboratory prism at
the University of Lille to learn more
about our speakers please visit the
speaker tab at the top of the
presentation window Nina in Phillips you
may now begin your presentation so Thank
You Michelle for the very kind
introduction thank you so today we will
talk about clinical uses of mass
spectrometry specifically focusing on
the new advances of the past years which
we believe will make a huge impact in
the clinical world so just to be more
specific we will be talking about the
methods which are not yet routinely used
but that have a great potential of being
used in oncology either during surgery
or during a pathological exams so first
just a bit of introduction of about mass
spectrometry in clinics in these days it
is routinely used to diagnose metabolism
deficiencies to determine biomarkers and
enzymes then for biological
toxicological testing and there are many
advantages of mass spectrometry over
other techniques because they can be
used to analyze fluid and solid tissue
and not really a lot of amount of sample
is necessary there is no labeling
required we can multiplex analysis we
can obtain detail molecular identity we
can do qualitative quantitative analysis
and we can analyze a large variety of
biomolecules such as metabolize proteins
and pharmaceutical compounds and also
what is nice about these methods that we
can use them for targeted or untargeted
analysis and the last part is really
more relevant for discovery based
research there are several groups of
techniques which have been involved in
clinical research such as classical mass
spectrometry techniques used in clinical
laboratory and
for example GT and LPNs mass
spectrometry imaging has been used as
well as ambient techniques and the
recently is the development of intra
operative techniques also called
IOM s used for real-time and in vivo
analysis during surgeries so let's just
briefly go through the classical
techniques here we outline a short
timeline of the important events of the
techniques that have been routinely used
in clinical labs so historically the
major impacts have been made by
confirmation of immunoassays with
positive drug screens by GCMs the
identification of inborn errors of
metabolism and analysis of steroid
hormones
more recently ms has dramatically
improved the time required for micro by
micro microbial identification and this
is the part that we will also speak a
little bit more about
once direct screening became mandatory
for employees in us several toxicology
as a lab started using this technology
and several studies have demonstrated
that urine testing was very cost
effective and they also started using
this methodology for four other four
other analysis such as your therapeutic
drug monitoring the major limitation of
GC NS is that the analyte needs to be
volatile and the foremost clinical stage
requires the multiple extraction and
purification steps along with the
chemical derivatives Asian to randomly
analyze sufficiently volatile analysis
atmospheric pressure ionization
techniques such as the electrospray
ionisation combined with AI performance
and TMS while the next major analytical
improvement that enabled ms for clinical
laboratory uses so indeed this
technology is very high throughput and
cost-effective especially the developer
of multiplex analysis and in the
microbiology lab lab the development of
MALDI combined with top mass analyzers
allowed for rapid identification of
microbes
for implementation of mallet of
microbiology laboratory depended on gram
stain's culture biochemical tests and
susceptibility testing but with the
development of the Brooker bio typer it
became very simple and very fast so
basically what happens is that after
culturing this mirrors are deposited on
to metallic sample plate and mixed with
multi matrices these are just regular
organic matrices the sample plate is
inserted in the instrument and a laser
is shot onto the sample for analysis the
molecules are then desorbed and ionized
and separated based on their mass to
charge ratio in the top analyzer you can
see a very nice schematic in the middle
of the slide the specific Peaks are then
generated are generated and compared to
the spectral libraries that is as as
estimated that using these techniques
has got the total cost of reagents and
Labor's by 50 percent which is a great
advance the spectral library can be
custom ly modified so users can build
their own database so this is just one
of the great example of ms being used in
everyday clinical analysis so now we
have reached now we have reached a part
which we want to emphasize more about
which is a recap of technological
advancements that we believe will have a
really important part into the clinical
world we will present these techniques
and a lot of use nice examples performed
either in the clinical or biomedical lab
doll aids we will start with explaining
about MALDI this was developed in 1985
by car essential intent that uses
solid-state samples mixed with specific
molecular matrix to generate gas phase
ions to be analyzed
in the late 90s MLG msi was introduced
and demonstrated its best potential for
biomarker discovery and has played a
central role in clinical research
linking classical histology and
molecular analysis so here are a few
break points such as the identifications
of first diagnostic markers but also
integration with astrology peptide MSI
analysis on AFP tissue and lad the
multicenter studies in a way to
standardize these techniques so here we
have the MALDI imaging ms this technique
allows us to directly map molecular
species such as proteins step-size
lipids and metabolites and is considered
a cutting-edge approach to better
understand underlying processes in cells
and viola so on top you can see a slide
with the tissue section with apply g
matrix we shoot the laser on top of the
section and the molecules are dissolved
and ionized and then furthermore
analyzed in the mass spectrometer on the
upper right side you can see the mass
spectrum that is created and if we
select a specific mass we can actually
generate a two dimensional map of this
specific mass
MALDI MSI is used in discovery-based
research for biomarker discovery as I
mentioned it can be used to analyze
metabolites lipids and proteins we can
analyze fresh frozen tissue FFP tissue
but we have to be aware that a specific
sample preparation is required depending
on what kind of molecules we would like
to detect so in cancer research and miss
MSI has been used for tumor typing and
especially the identification of tumor
origin in metastatic tissues as well as
grading and may provide prognostic
information while looking at the tumor
microenvironment we can study for
example a hypoxia derived prognostic
biomarkers such as glycans which can be
used to predict cancer progression and
patient outcome for personalized
medicine so here is a an example on the
bottom right corner of the analysis of a
tumor in Hodgenville at about unity and
on the bottom-left corner an example of
analysis of glycans on tissue mccoy's
where we can distinguish some specific
signals in tumor and non tumors tissues
so one of the main breakthroughs in this
field as we mentioned already previously
is the possibility to image not only
fresh frozen but also FFPE tissue which
gives us access to large clinical
tissues FFP stands for formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded in which the fresh
tissues are fixed in formalin and then
transfer for conservation so here I will
just show you briefly how the sample
preparation of these tissues work so
first we have an FFA slide
which is cut to appropriate thicknesses
we wash the tissue and specific solvent
to remove lipids and policin we do the
antigen retrieval step to break the
disulfide bonds of proteins which were
caused by the fixation we spray trypsin
or for other enzymes in order to break
the proteins into smaller peptides and
then the final step is to apply the
matrix on top of the tissue
here is just two images which show the
distribution of specific triptych ly
digested peptides and the mass spectra
that we usually acquire so here we can
see an example of the film reanalysis of
patients with the high-grade serous
casino MO and a round robin study of FFP
DNA analysis I don't go further in
details of this Kimbra example as we
will dig deeper into it later but not
only can we see proteins but also we can
see metabolites in these 15 so these
strategies MSI allow us to obtain the
spatial distribution of whole of
adjusted proteins but the idealistic
identification is still very difficult
directly from the tissues in fact it
really relies on ms/ms fragmentation
spectral quality so for a long time
top-down FST analysis was difficult and
for bottom up strategy the enzymatic
digestion is complicated to read so how
could we breach this localization aspect
to the classical large-scale proteomics
don't I teach through extraction and a
CMS well in prism lab we aimed at
filling this gap and correlate the
protein localization with their
identification by using specially
resolved micro proteomics so what
happens is that we use Pacific
techniques call them micro sampling by
the liquid micro Junction micro
extraction with liquid extraction
surface analysis Russa and in this
particular example what we have done is
that we use the segmentation analysis on
a small d image of a red brain we were
able to select specific regions on which
we did two specifics micro extraction
on approximately 1900 South extracted
thousand and 350 identified protein
proteins were found specifically a major
majority of them were common between the
zones but we also sign between 200 and
300 of protein specific to each position
so we tested them the Republic the
reproducibility of the extraction by
processing several following slides of
the brain at exactly the same location
which showed us less than 5% variation
in the protein content between each run
one of the main application in the
technique of the technique in the lab is
to study the Cimbri are presenting
high-grade serous carcinoma this
specific a GSC series represents 85 days
of epithelial cancer of the reproductive
organs and it's partition in 70% of
serous type and 30% of Nokomis state
when the lesions usually diagnosed
deletions are usually diagnosed in the
advanced stages so the prognosis is
usually bad even with heavy surgery and
chemotherapy by analysis by an icing
digestant proteins we were first able to
analyze this tumor and detect specific
molecular signatures that were that we
extensively studied by using a chemical
inkjet printer to deposit trypsin
directly onto discrete regions of less
than one millimeter scope so after
protein digestion the liquid we
conjunction is performed to retrieve all
the peptides that were digested and that
are coming from the identification of
proteins in both cancer and benign
regions our campaigns
it has been possible by this approach to
obtain different important signaling
pathways involved in cancer processes
and some proteins already known as
biomarkers in the geography
the comprehension of the pathology has
really evolved these past 10 years and
clinicians now think that the majority
of the ovarian cancer arising not from
the ovarian tissue but from the embryo
part of the fallopian tube
the communication between these
secretory cells of the embryo and the
ovarian epithelium by especially
reactive oxygen species or rows of
believed to induce a molecular
differentiation of the secretory
population into click on cells feelings
and these regions are often detected
from brca1 mutated patients who
undergone or selected over ectomy and
can be traced from p53 lesions to
different intermediate grade rates
leading to the migration of cancerous
cells on the ovarian causing addresses a
GSC so in order to evaluate the
progression of the lesions it to HD SC
we decided to look for those small
numbers of cells which are bearing
specific phenotypes of precancerous
lesions the originality of our approach
was to use the p53 and ki-67
immunohistochemistry staining obtained
during routine analysis of pathologists
so after they analyzed these slides and
detect the second source lesions they
gave them to us to be analyzed so when
the cells were responding a delta p53
ki-67 or both then we use that entering
to the universal chemistry to direct our
analysis so we first unmount our cover
slips from the slides and then we use
them for imaging and micro extraction
extraction
to lc/ms analysis we were able to
significantly the different lesions
based on their proteins we could
distinguish the pathways between the
early stages of normal p53 and still
samples which showed an overexpression
of the silicon for mediating signaling
pathways that affect cellular
proliferation migration and endocytosis
but also integrins family cell surface
interactions which are involved in
metastasis
so the
widely used techniques in a math
analysis was invented in parallel to non
G and is the electrospray ionization or
easy it was developed by Fanning
collaborators in 1984 in this technique
the the analytes are present in a liquid
phase and this is solvent is created in
front of a mass spectrometer and on we
apply an electrical current in order to
promote the ionization of the analytes
by definition the ionization sources is
working under atmospheric pressure or
aims so the samples that we analyzed can
be in the native space so just to go
quickly through some of the points in
the timeline for the creation of nano is
a to improve protein identification by
lc/ms then the creation of daddy to
perform imaging mass spectrometry lacey
for laser ablation electrospray analysis
and previously mentioned some in here
we just want to mention that desi has
been the most widely spread among them
today to do 2d and 3d imaging either for
tumor lipid profiles tumor subtyping or
prediction of metastatic status
in this variable technique of
atmospheric pressure mass spectrometry
will focus on some of them and begin
with in panel a will be desi an aside so
in this schematic diagram we can see how
an electrospray is directed onto the
sample surface to desorb molecules that
are then analyzed and its application to
brain tumor
so the top spectrum shows the low-to-mid
cell concentration region infiltrating
into the gray matter and the bottom
spectrum shows the CMS of dense
tumor regions with high tumor cell
concentration just under we can see desi
ms iron image which shows the
distribution of specific
glycerophospholipids depending on the
area so the second technique depress the
MSO probe electrospray mass spectrometry
shows the principle of the operation so
the probe is held in contact with the
tissue to be analyzed and then it's
placed inside of the as a mobilization
plume here we show the application to
colon cancer and on the top and the
bottom spectrum with the presence of
specific glycerophospholipids in either
normal or cancerous colon tissue
so in panels see the diagram explain us
how the TSN eyes works for touch prey ms
so similar to the busy needle adsorbed
molecules of interest by touching solids
or solutions then this needle is covered
with a small drops of solvent and we
apply a current on it to directly
generate a spray at its tip so in the
application here the prostate cancer
analysis is showed with its mass
spectrum which is revealing the presence
of specific molecules in the region
outlined below which correspond on the
biopsy to prostate malignant tissue so
as it was determined by Esther palace'
logical evaluation so on the right hand
side you can see a table which
summarizes the potentially relevant aims
techniques you can be used in the ultra
operative circumstances and the
principle molecules or biomolecules that
can be seen with these commitments we
will dig a little bit further in the
into the following part right after this
recap slide so
to summarize how does how do molecular
information obtained by ms can be
related to health and disease well you
know in fact any small modification in
overpasses leads to changes in
biological pathways and when pathology
brings imbalance the molecular profiles
are dysregulated and all biomolecules
are equally affected so basically by
following proteins and lipids can
therefore get insight into health and
disease states
so now we have reached in part of our
presentation corresponding to the
emergence of the more or less real-time
and in vivo techniques which have been
created since 2010 the first one was
developed was developed in in UK
intelligence a knife based on Reims
rapid evaporative a ionization mass
spectrometry
and so although techniques are used with
ranges as the sampling method like the
pearl for people ii infrared laser mass
spectrometry developed in 2015 and the
spider masks
developed by the Prisma laboratory in
2014 then in 2017 the math back pain was
introduced
the ions techniques are developed to
help with the cancer diagnosis and
margin evaluation principally which are
difficult to observe during the
pathological exam and that can take
between 30 to 40 minutes during surgery
in classical operation there are two
main approaches one which is off line
and watch one with which is on line
the first one is taking the sample out
of the patient and perform effect on
potenuse analysis in the room next to
the operating theatre it can be a
biological or pathology lab the second
approach is the use of a surgical Henty
temple directly by the serger and
performed in vivo and in real-time so
here are the several techniques that
have been developed over the years in
this field such as the ionized
technology developed by Zoltan caucus at
the Imperial College of London the
spider mass system developed here in
prism labs the mass spec pen developed
by a Berlin lab in University of Texas
in Austin Austin LD AMS develop isotopes
in 2009 in Germany the Perl developed by
Doreen SR in University of Toronto and
stereotactic TMS developed by a girl lab
at Harvard Medical School in Boston but
in this final example they used as the
extra SM for example Arius analysis but
all of these techniques are in common
the same goal to help cancer diagnosis
and to ultimately help the patient
survival in outcome so we will mainly
focus and explain the uses of the knife
the mass spec then in the spider mass
technology to give you a taste of the
different methodology used
so first we will start off with the
ionized technology here is the first
system so the intelligent I my based on
rate the ionized produces gas phase ions
of evaporated tissue after the contact
with the surgical tool because phase
ions are then subsequently transmitted
to the mass spectrometer through the
Teflon to the Teflon tubing or tygon
tubing which is biocompatible which can
be more than 1 meter length using a
venturi jet jet pump so this technique
is compatible with the commonly used
surgical devices such as the electro
cylindrical electrodes but also surgical
diathermy people are four sets of
curvature an ultrasonic logical operator
and utilizes the surgical area I also
saw smokes
form doing normal surgical interventions
the analyse detection detected our
metabolites and lipids in the negative
ion mode polarity so the analysed
molecular signatures are then subjected
to classification using multivariate
classifiers so over the years it has
been used in different applications such
as the oncologist surgery breast cancer
diagnostic and margin assessment brain
tumor analysis industrial internist and
gastroenterology such as implementation
of an endoscopic system and the
atmospheric pressure bio typing so the
other techniques we mentioned is the
mass segments so it consists of a
syringe pump delivering a defined water
volume to the sampling probe which we
can see here on the right side of the
screen it's connected to PTFE tubing
which are integrated with valve to
transfer the water to and from the
tissue this device is the pen size for
probing of biological
so during the experiments as we can see
on the left side of the screen a water
droplet is deposited onto the tissue for
three second period allowing the
attraction extraction of the analytes so
this droplet is vacuum extracted to the
mass spectrometer and analyze the system
is based on non-destructive liquid solid
destruction and can be applied in vivo
for in vivo tissue analysis
so here's just a couple of examples of
how the mass effect pen has been used in
different applications while subjected
to moly various statistical analysis and
here we can see a different example such
as breast cancer acai riod cancer ovary
cancer and lung cancer with the to
classify between normal and cancer
tissues with a large number of patients
so now let's go to the spider math
system which we are developing in the in
the lab for in vivo and real-time
analysis using a laser in the ephra red
wavelength and this system was
introduced in 2014 so the spider base is
tuned to excite the most intense
vibrational band of water molecules at
2.94 micro minute micrometer you know
process described as water assisted
laser desorption and ionization so the
spider master system is composed of the
mini invasive laser microprobe to
generate the ions which is the first
part of the system then we have a
transfer line which is transferring in
real time the I analyzed from the probe
to the MS systems and then the acquired
molecular spectra are then subjected to
multivariate analysis and classification
models are built based on the different
tissue type so basically what happens is
that we can teach we can teach the
muscle to recognize for example cancer
or normal tissue once the model is
created we can interrogate the model in
vivo this has already been performed in
one of our previous studies and ianka
vet clinic indeed since the data is very
complex to analyze and we are often very
limited with the amount of tissue we
have been currently developing software
based on DNA and in this current state
these spider medicine provides the
imaging such
so the spider mass prototypes can be
connected to the mass spectrometer we
have the biocompatible tygon tubing and
two different variety of mass
spectrometers here are a few here are
the few examples um it can be linked to
a queue top instruments such as the
synapse and Devo from waters or high
mass resolution spectrometers such as
the Orbitrap that really shows the
versatility of the technique and the
adaptation depending on the user's needs
we also did quite a lot of different
applications with a spider med system in
the first upper top left corner you can
see the example how non-invasive each
spider my system is because we were able
to perform analysis in vivo on skin we
can see the different metabolites and
lipids that are coming off from the
tissue
the technique is also able to analyze
protein standards deposited on the
sample holder here is an example on the
bottom left on the bottom left part of
how we analyze protein standards such as
the pigmenting and gives us the
electrospray like spectra with a
multiplied chart state the last example
on the top right corner you can see the
bacterial bio typing where we were able
to separate different strands of
bacteria based on their molecular
profiles
but one of the major studies was
conducted on dog sarcoma samples
Takuma is the type of highly
heterogeneous tumor which are difficult
from time to time to distinguish by
apology so you know in Moore there is a
large number of pathological type of
Tacoma so we were we were up to the
challenge to see whether we can
distinguish between normal and cancerous
tissues and different pathological types
so in this study we used so ex-vivo
biopsies obtained from surgery of dogs
we had to cut these samples in half to
have a morphological control and the
spyder math analysis on its mirror
please so using these techniques to
generate the spectra corresponding to
each situation we were able to to to
classify the samples according to their
biological content so we can see on the
top on the bottom corner that the PCA is
showing really a nice separation between
the normal and the cancerous tissues and
we can also see that the cancerous
tissues are split into subgroups which
we will extend your region just right
after
so in fact this separation is coming
from the presence of necrotic tissues
inside the cancerous subtype and we have
been able to create a classification
model taking into account this necrosis
signals so the using this system we were
able to see that the necrosis part is
really distinguishing from the cancerous
one and the normal tissues on the top
right side of the slide you can see that
we were able to classify the sarcoma
according to the grade which is great
for grading during surgery
so we did some across validation of the
markets detected with the Spyro mask
using the MAL DMS a technique which has
a father
proven to be robust so here we can see
that we have some specific markers from
the normal on top and cancerous on the
bottom part regions and dues the signals
are I were identified in real-time and
some markers share their specific
localization between the spider mass and
then all the MSI
so in order to do to interrogate the
classification model in real time and to
do the actual assessment of one of the
tissues we selected a tissue which has a
mixed composition of normal cancer and
necrosis we we started shooting the
tissue and based on the Emmis spectra
acquired we interrogated the
classification model and give us back
the real-time classification feedback
and as you can see it was able to
specify between normal cancer and
necrosis part of the tissue
so then we went to the vet surgery room
to to see if the system is able to work
during surgeries so we first installed
the system and set decided the surgeon
while doing these surgeries we were
getting the ex vivo biopsy and analyzing
them in real time then we gave the
handful directly to the to the surgeons
which used it during these surgeries and
the generated mass spectra showed their
ability to be linked to tissue specific
molecular profiles and for the last
example we want to show you that we are
able to do direct protein analysis of
human saliva here we use the 5
microliters of human saliva with five
microliters of si and water and a CN
directly onto a glass slide and analyzed
the mess that's were produced as you can
see we have a lot of specifically Peaks
and then we also have this match range
where we can see mainly the proteins and
here one of these proteins came started
really popping up which these as a mess
875 0.8 we perform some ms/ms analysis
and we were able to see that we detect
celebrity as acidic protein reach
forceful protein 1/2 which is present in
the human saliva DPR h1 that we detect
provided a protective and reparative
environment for the dental enamel so as
you can see we really can use the spider
mask technology in a variety of
different application in the clinical
world
so to recap how the spider-man's
development prism can help clinicians in
their daily routine please
well the pyramid can help providing any
type of material as which showed and
giving its molecular signature like a
barcode so these can then be used to
differentiate between various classes of
samples and classify them so on during
surgery it can be used for grading
modeling detection and even extent of
rejection assessment without damaging
the surrounding tissues
and let's not forget that in the lab it
can be used for drug screaming bacterial
bio typing a most other non clinical
related application like pesticide
analysis or food safety
so let the our last learning objectives
was to treat how the Alma development
has advanced in the clinical labs and
Hospital so it has developed from vacuum
based ms to AMS and from process to
direct analysis of samples the MS
technology has made a lot of huge step
forward in these advocates bringing us
into the era of in vivo and real-time
analysis plus the bioinformatics tools
that have been developed have part of
the ability to analyze huge data sets
and make classification or discover new
biomarkers
so we wanted to finish this talk by
thanking all of the prizm members which
are doing a great state of the art work
obtaining these deep analysis using
imaging and multi-omics techniques for
diagnosis and prognosis biomarker
venting our aims are to better
understand the physio pathology in
oncology and in Neurology and discover
new mechanism to treat them by their
article or technological innovations
and we want to specifically thank the
partners involved in the spider mass
project and last but not least all of
you for attending this webinar and we
will be more than happy to answer any of
your questions and thank you for your
attention
thank you
Thank You Nina and Philip for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
our speakers will answer as many
questions as time permits okay let's get
started our first question is when do we
expect the first experiment performed
during human surgery
so we expect our first experiments to be
performed in 2026 yeah which is the
quite objectives because we have several
steps to to achieve before going into
the surgery room because it's really the
last and the more important goal of the
project
great thank you okay next question when
do we expect to sell the first
commercial spider mass prototype
at the moment we have a lab prototype
but we plan soon to have something to be
available so we think that maybe next
year in the next two years we will be
able to commercially provide prototypes
in order to run at least research in
vitro and outreach for now yes exactly
thank you okay it looks like we have
time for one more question is
is there any link between all the omics
database for example genomic
transcriptomic
proteomic and genomic data or lipid omec
data well that's a huge question in fact
there is no direct link between the
genomics transcriptomics and proteomics
data banks and omics results as we know
today more and more that not every gene
which is expressed is transferred into a
protein what we can say still is that
maybe we can do the link between the
lipid omics data we are generating and
the Palio mcdhh at a-- we have when
there is a direct link between the
protein and biosynthesis of the lipid in
questions
I would like to once again thank Nina
and Philip for their presentations I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and further interesting
questions any questions we did not have
time for today will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration we
would like to thank lab roots and our
educational sponsor Adeline for today's
educational webcast mavar's will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's event until next time
goodbye